Fans like to create content
based on your game.
And by encouraging
them to create content,
you can help promote your game and
make your players feel invested.
As a bonus, you also get to
see their creativity at work.
And invested players will
help your game make money.
Fan art is a great example of this.
And here's an example
from League of Legends.
Another example of player created
content are extended in game
experiences, which are generally ways
for players to personalize the game and
create scenarios that
are the most interesting to them.
A great example of this is Minecraft.
It gives users a simple set of tools and
resources that they can build off of to
create their own challenges and worlds.
They can create dungeons
filled with zombies or
lava, games that take place in the air
or places made entirely of gold.
Players can even recreate scenarios
from their favorite movies,
like with this superhero character and
stormtrooper.
In all these scenarios, players
are taking the core of the game and
customizing it based on
their own interests.
The more your game supports
content creators and
is able to celebrate their creations,
the more invested your players will be
and the more depth and variety you'll
have in your gaming experience.